hannah damals jugend herzlich willkommen
ja heute meine lieben freunde zu einem
neuen video auf meinem kanalbau das hat
mich mal platz weltmeister
wir haben uns das heutige video eine
lustige challenge überlegt und zwar
haben wir hier buchstaben drin verteilte
sie nicht gestorben sondern ein zettel
auf den buchstaben darauf stehen jedoch
von uns vergleiche ziehen dann werden
wir gleichzeitig die buchstaben
auspacken und dann direkt mit unserem
handy und selbst filmen das handy hat
übrigens mit einem wunderschönen
popsongs klinischer von de wir werden
uns dann auf jeden fall selbst so self
mäßig filmen wie wir in der wohnung fünf
gegenstände zusammen suchen die mit dem
buchstaben die mir gezogen haben
anfangen davon machen wir drei kunden
wie so gern sei ja der als erstes fünf
gegenstände gefunden hat ruft dann ganz
laut stopp und dann muss der andere
aufhören zu suchen und dann werden die
gegenstände die halt präsentiert impact
unseren buchstaben aus und 32
ich habe ich hab' ich kenne nicht mal
ein wort mit y
schön dass du deine rang
bücher portemonnaie y
[Musik]
ja ihr könnt noch einmal eine self care
ich anschauen
es geht ich habe im pcie lawn google
jetzt erst mal das für wörz ist mit dem
slon gibt es ein paar sekunden später
yoga qi happy denn jan insel starb ich
hab nichts solche sachen vor mit
pflanzen super portmonee soll das sagt
papierkorb hier von klasse fünf punkte
für jule und null punkte für mich
allerdings kann es sein dass du es tiefe
nicht irgendwie a oder b oder keine
ahnung was und dann mach ich fünf punkte
du warst dementsprechend 0 von daher
doch vorgestellte drei runden machen
allerdings nicht versagen kann unseren
stamm aus und das ist schon rein 321
auto mein gott okay warum wissen habe
ich denn die sachen mit vl haben
bestimmt das bild ist aber ich habe
viele playstations ventilator eine volt
batterie kann einfach dass ein batterie
ist oder was überhaupt nur volt batterie
ist aber jubelte schon das ist aber ich
werde darauf also oder die sachen die
ich habe sind erstens tantum werte also
was aber es ist das zweite wort das
zählt nicht
dann habe ich viele playstation spiele
videos wie videospiele genau videospiele
dann habe ich ein nächstes einen
ventilator das ist ja etwas von
auszusetzen brauche ich eine volle
batterie sondern habe ich ja einen
rucksack das zählt auch nicht diese das
richtig obwohl die hitze und ich hab die
fünf punkte gegeben
schnell ein schalter bedienen dass keine
fernbedienung das ist ein lampen an
macher des zählt nächsten fühlen das ist
ein defibrillator und lassen das ist
wasser
mein gott okay war ich möchte gar keinen
punkt leben
wir kommen um zu letzten alles
entscheidenden runde steht 8 zu 3 für
jule von daher muss ich jetzt komplett
gewinn und darf nichts finden also ich
würde sagen mit den ersten buchstaben
oder satz erst mit den letzten
buchstaben für dieses video für heute
und er packt ihn aus und 321 co die
du hast du schon geworden oben liegen
bei einer anhaltend balladen
was hab ich denn mit ende nichts sagt
ich habe nichts mit meiner wohnung
gegenstände new balance uhr starb eine
zweite sache ist die bürste dann habe
ich einen blender
dann habe ich mit beauty luca und ich
habe blut fuß 41 cool ich habe nichts
das ist meine erste gegenstand ich habe
die balance schuhe das zeitalter warum
zählt dass sie nicht schwanger alter ist
ein gibt's ein kopf der gruppe
entsprechend tochter dann lassen wir das
zähne weil wird eng seine schuhe die die
rebellen schwer dass er noch zwei
gegenstände und nicht sagen ich habe
zehn mal nichts gefunden
also als schlussendlich habe ich
eigentlich gewonnen wenn du das video
hier gefallen hat trotz dessen dass
suchen wir natürlich komplett überzogen
und verlogen und unfair gewonnen sind da
war es auf jeden fall gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video ihr da schreibt
dass bei uns in die kommentare was ich
beispielsweise bei y hätte finden können
oder bei frau oder bei n weil das sind
alles sehr blöde buchstaben abonniert
hermann kant noch keinen seit der luxus
seit die tage kommt auf jeden fall auch
ein neues video mit juden in minecraft
ich will ich gar nicht einmal so ein fan
ist
[Musik]